I've never said that I mean like
everything I have everything I've said
um suggests that it's not about
isolation and that that way of looking
at societies is discrete and n discrete
packages that are not the you know that
rub up against each other but they're
not interconnected that doesn't work
anymore so this idea of leave this set
of people known or leave that set of
people own is not like that's as far
from my mentality as one could get I
think the ideas I mean if anything what
I'm saying is bring more people in let's
bring as many people as we can into
whatever discussion that we're having so
that we hear all those voices and so
that we we develop new ways of
interacting with each other not just the
same frames that we've been putting
forth over and over again but like you
know let's let's let's see who has
something to say and that's you know if
they're if they're opinion or if they're
idea is invalid then well it will be
discredited but the bottom line is it
needs to be put out there but if their
idea or opinion is is valid and no one
ever gets to hear it because they're not
at the table or because you say that
like this society shouldn't interact
with that society for whatever reason
that's the problem that's a really big
problem and you know if anything what I
want to do with my life and what I'm
what I hope you know that I've started
doing is saying let's get these stories
let's get these ideas and let's put them
together and let's see how we can bring
people closer rather than saying no you
guys don't know anything about this just
stay to your side are you guys you know
just stay in your corner that I think
that's the the least productive way of
addressing any issue that we have to
deal with today
you